اذا من الشمالين الشرقي والغربي تصب ايران
وتركيا غضبهما لاسباب مختلفه على منطقه
واحده كردستان العراق بالامس كانت تركيا
واليوم ايران فالحرس الثوري اعلن عن شن
هجمات جديده استهدفت مجموعات كرديه
ايرانيه في كردستان العراق قالت القوات
البريه الايرانيه ان العمليه التي تمت
بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره استهدفت
مقرات لتدريب وتنظيم تلك المجموعات في
مخيمي ديزني كان وزرغيز ومدينه
واوضحت في بيان انه تم خلالها هذه الهجمات
تدمير الاهداف المقصوده والحاق خسائر
كبيره بالمجموعات الكرديه في المقابله
اعلنت اجهزه مكافحه الارهاب في كردستان
العراق ان الضربات طالت اهداف كرديه بينما
كشف المستهدفان الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني الايراني والتنظيم كومالا
القومي الايراني عن تضر عدد من منشاته ما
شمال العراق ايران كانت اتهمت هذه
المجموعات الكرديه باثاره الاحتجاجات داخل
البلاد منذ منذ مقتل مهساميني كما وجه عدد
من المسؤولين التحذيرات بهذا الصدد
للسلطات في بغداد واربيل لكن الحسبه
الديمقراطيه لكردستانيه الايرانيه اعتبر
في بيان على تويتر ان النظام يداري
بهجماته العشوائيه عجزه عن وقف التظاهرات
الجاريه في كردستان ايران وعموم البلاد
[موسيقى]